all right the last talk of the session
and of the week
uh will be given by nicholas brookman
and he'll talk about twisted product
constructions
for ldpc quantum codes yeah
hi everyone thank you very much for the
invitation
so my talk will deal about some risk
developments
in quantum error correction and in
particular i will talk about
three different constructions of
quantum codes using so-called twisted
products
um so let's start at the beginning in
1995
shawa invented quantum quantum codes in
order to show that quantum errors can be
corrected
and the vague or the overall arching
idea is that we can hide
a quantum state in non-local degrees of
freedom
of a larger system adding adding
redundancy
which we can kind of use to protect our
quantum information
and in order to
correct errors we can perform
check measurements which have to commute
of course to infer information about the
errors
but i will not talk about too much about
uh about this process i will just talk
about
um quantum codes themselves
um okay so um quantum codes are
parametrized
by uh three important uh parameters
so first of all the number of physical
qubits which we denote by n
then there's the number of encoded
qubits so how much information we can
encode
in our codon code and
a parameter which um
[Music]
which tells us how how good we are
protected against errors
is called the distance this is the
smallest weight of an
undetectable error
okay so classical codes can be described
simply by
a so-called parity check matrix so this
is just a binary matrix
with rows performing parity checks
and the kernel of this matrix
is some subspace of all possible
bit combinations and this subspace we
call a code
and similarly we can describe certain
types of quantum codes so-called css
quantum codes
by two parity-check matrices hx
and hz where hx performs
measurements against phase flip errors
and hz
performs measurements against bit flip
errors
and um i mentioned earlier that of
course our
observables have to commute and this
translates into the fact that these
matrices
have to multiply uh
to zero uh modulo 2 of course
and the reason why i will only talk
about css codes in this talk
is partially motivated by a result by
bravi lemos and tehal
and this result tells us that any
stabilizer code which is a larger family
of quantum codes
can be mapped onto a css code so we
don't actually
lose too much if we only care about the
scaling
of these parameters
so let's let's restrict ourselves a
little bit more
the the most reasonable
codes i would say are so called ldpc
quantum codes
and there are two conditions so first of
all i should say that
this notion also exists in the classical
world and
the definition definition is essentially
the same
we demand that each check operates on a
constant number of qubits or bits
and each bit or qubit should participate
only in a constant number of checks
so in terms of these parity check
matrices
these conditions just say that the party
check matrices of the classical code
or of the css codes must be sparse
um it turns out that it's
that there are classical ldpc codes
which are so called good codes
and good has a very precise definition
here good means that
the number of encoded bits scales
linearly with n
so the number of total of bits and the
distance gets linearly
in n so this is like the best asymptotic
scaling you can hope for
uh and this is even um these these
chords are actually quite
quite easy to get so even if you just
take a a random parity check matrix
which is sparse
uh with high probability you will have a
good code on your hands
um and a big open question is can ldpc
quantum codes be good
[Music]
and it turns out that this the single
condition that our checks have to
commute
makes this this question quite hard
so the intuition here is that let's say
we take
for hx we take the parity check matrix
of a good classical code
then because of this condition we see
that
the the rows of the z checks
which have to be in the kernel of the of
the x
cannot cannot have low support and
therefore h-z cannot be sparse
and to add insult to injury uh until
easily it wasn't even
clear whether we could have distances
scaling beyond the
polylog n times square root of n
so for this let me kind of just uh
briefly recap the
the history of ldp lpc quantum codes
with large distances
so first of all there was a story code
which of course has distance scaling
with the square root of n
then there was in 2002
um a slight improvement um which is
actually quite
quite a complicated construction due to
friedman maya enduro which improves uh
the distance scaling by the fourth root
of a log
so not by very much um then
of course a lot of things happened uh
great results were produced but there
wasn't much
uh happening in terms of um distance
records
uh until in 2020 a lot of stuff happened
uh
partially because maybe a lot of people
had a lot of time on their hands um
so first of all if our koffman and
zeymor improved
the polylog scaling by a squared
of a log n and then kaufman and ifram
tweaked this this construction
a bit further from month after and
actually showed that it's possible
to get arbitrary polydox in front of the
square root of n
but still some people believed that
there was a barrier
and it wasn't really clear whether this
barrier can be broken
until heist links ha and o'donnell
showed that
actually there are codes which which
breaks this
square polylog barrier significantly
by showing that there are codes with
distance scaling as n to the
three-fifths
of the pulley logs then
again shortly after pantalia kalachev
introduced
a different construction but related
construction
and they showed that actually they can
get as close as they want
to linearly scaling distance so only up
to a log factor
and then finally like a week later the
myself and my co-author we showed that
there is a third construction
and the difference to the to the first
two is that
the first two use randomness so these
parameters only only hold
with high probability whereas for us
this
result is unconditional and there are
also some
some extra nice features
that i will talk about later okay
so um just to kind of
give you an idea of what this will be
about
so there are product constructions which
take
two classical codes as inputs and they
produce a quantum code
and the nice thing is that the quantum
code actually inherits properties
of the of the input codes and this goes
under
different names um so i will i will i
will call this essentially the tensor
product
of two classical codes um
so the ideopark approach is quite
technical um
and i try to avoid this in the interest
of time
and not having to introduce too many
notions
so i will talk about this in terms of
topology and i hope
then the results will be intuitive
[Music]
so how do i talk about codes in terms of
topology
so let me give you an example let's take
a repetition code on three bits
so the chord words so this is a
classical code the chords words are just
0 0 0 and 1 1 1
and this code is defined by three parity
checks
um just checking the parity of uh the
first two and then the
second the third and the first and the
third
and um i can turn this into a picture
of a circle by identifying the bits with
the edges
and the vertices with the checks okay
so i can turn the repetition code into
just a cyclic
cyclic graph
okay and now this product construction
is uh can be simply understood as just a
a product of two cycles and the product
of two cycles is simply a torus
and um this notion essentially
linear arises and in fact the tauric
codes
which you see on the right hand side
might be familiar with it
is that can be obtained as a product of
two repetition codes
so i can express this in terms of
matrices so h1 is just the
uh h1 and h2 i just the parry check
matrices
that i've showed you before and you can
convince yourself by doing the simple
algebra that this
in fact these two checkmates commute
but we make a following observation um
the
uh due to the kronecker product that you
see
[Music]
appearing here the size of the quantum
code
is the product of the input code length
however it turns out that the the
distance is just
the same as for the input codes and
what this tells us is that we can at
most achieve a square root distance so
we want
we're not going to be able to break the
polylog
squared and barrier so what hastings
have done
observed and actually this idea is also
present in this earlier
paper by friedman meyer is that we can
introduce
twists in some sense to
increase the distance so going back to
the story code example so you have on
the left hand side i've drawn
a torus so the opposite sides are
identified
however i have kind of kind of done it
performed a twist in the middle
and in the tory code all that you have
to know is that
the the distance is given by the
shortest non-protectable loop
so if you have an l by l taurus then the
distance is simply l
and by performing this twist i have
actually increased length of one of
these loops
so for a non-contractable loop to kind
of go around the torus
the twist kind of introduces a detour
that the the
loop has to make to kind of uh close up
on itself
okay so um these twists can be
uh described in the language of fiber
bundles which are objects
which are at home in differential
geometry and these are described in
terms of a base manifold
and then a fiber manifold and local
data which describes the the twists
and what hastings sound will not show is
that um
if they take a random code as the base
and they take a circle as a fiber
so a circle i always mean a revolution
codes
and they just kind of introduce random
twists between the between the fibers
then they achieve a distance scaling as
n to the three fifths
up to polylogs with high probability
okay let me let me
be slightly less fake so
the the base code let's say has n
prime bits and the fiber is a revision
code
which we choose as of length
of the same length as the as the base
coat
and the twists have to kind of go
along length of a square root of l
then um the total code um
has uh n squared
n prime squared qubits so the idea here
being
again like this um i'm trying to make
this um
uh very intuitive so we just took a
product
between uh the the base coat which is
just this
this is disk and we take a fiber which
which introduces the z direction so
these things just
multiply
the encoded degrees of freedom are
simply
given through the base code and since
the base code can be a good code this
can scale with
n-prime and what they then show
and unfortunately can't give you a good
intuition for this because this is based
on
probabilistic arguments is that the
x-distance
scales with square root of l times n
prime
so this gives us a distance scaling as n
to the 3
4 with high probability and that
distance
essentially scales with l so this means
we get a distance
of uh n to the one half
okay but um as you can see we are still
limited by the
z distance so if the distances are
different we
agreed that we take the the lower one
um so we are kind of still limited
limited in this in this case so um
what they do is um they perform another
product
and this product is taken
together with a classical code
so as an input we take a quantum code
with some parameters
we take a classical code and we obtain a
quantum code
where again the size just is given by
the product of the codes
uh the encoded bits or qubits
are just given by the the product of the
encoded qubits and the encoded bits
and the distances either stay the same
or they multiply and
again an intuitive picture here is if
you're familiar with the surface code we
could just take a surface code which is
imbalanced
meaning we have say one distance is much
larger than the other distance
then we can just take a product again we
obtain
a three-dimensional version of the of
the surface code
[Music]
and uh one of the one of the uh
logical operators will become sheet like
and
um the other operator essentially kind
of stays the same
and uh yeah using this trick we can kind
of balance out between between the two
distances
okay so now we observe that if
the product of the x distance and the z
distance scales faster than the square
root of n
we can break the barrier and in their
example
this was exactly the case so they obtain
a code which has distance scaling with
end to the three-fifth
[Music]
there's one caveat though they have to
assume that
their random code has polylog check rate
so
the resulting code will not be ldbc so
it will not have a constant check rate
however this can be fixed but the
the issue here is that they have to
introduce more qubits so this is where
this polylog factor
comes from
okay so this brings us to lifted
products
first of all other questions so far
[Music]
so you have the random base code
yeah that one where's the twist
oh okay so sorry yeah i i kind of
brushed over this um
so um in in in black i kind of show what
uh what the local structure is in the in
the base coat
and then in blue is what it looks like
in the in the fiber bundle
so uh you can see that uh the um
what used to be nearest neighbors in the
base codes now are kind of far apart
in the in the fiber bundle and this is
exactly this twist uh
of of length uh square root of l
so the the in the in the product uh we
kind of i know stretch out
uh uh uh things which used to be local
in the base codes and we can stretch
them out all over the
uh all over the fiber that's kind of the
idea and this is then kind of i know
translates into this
into this distance bound and i hope i
can kind of give you more intuition
in the other product notions of where
this kind of comes from
okay
and again please please feel free to
interrupt me at any at any point
[Music]
okay um so the second notion of of
products
uh are the uh lifted products um and
these are a bit more
uh technical um so we can try my best
to uh highlight the main main points
so the main idea is um instead of
describing uh
uh instead of taking the tensor product
of classical codes uh just over
uh f2 um over these so the the the
tensor product of
of the of the classic codes as i showed
before
were these binary matrices
and instead of doing that we
substitute this by the product of an l
dimensional commutative
algebra which is binary
and the check matrices look the same so
these
you've seen before however the entries
are now entries in
r and in fact we can kind of pull
so what the swiffer plot means is we can
we can pull
elements of r from one side to the other
and um uh what this gives us is
that the the
check matrices will be smaller by a
factor of of l
uh since um the um
uh the algebra elements in r can be
represented this is like an l
dimensional algebra so they can be
represented by l by l matrices
so this is where this is where the
factor of l
roughly comes from
and we can consider a special case
so the specific case is the f2 algebra
which is generated by a single element
which
is of order l and
so we just take this as the algebra and
as the second code we just again take
a replication code of length l so the
checks are just
generated by algebra elements one plus x
so you could think of this as just as
the um
the nearest number of checks the nearest
name of parity checks
of the repetition code
and just again to kind of i i appreciate
that this is
quite technical so just to kind of give
you more intuition the connection to
hastings how donald
is that you can think as x as
a shift operator along along the fiber
so in fact the the object we construct
is
more or less exactly the same just in a
different different language
so the um uh
the there is a fiber which is described
by this by this um that is algebra
and again there's a a product with
another code which is which is a random
code and
similarly to the 5 bundle construction
we perform random lifts of this base
code
and this will give us random twists
and by doing so there's slightly more
structure than
in the hastings how do i
work so they actually avoid this problem
of
of weight reduction and um
so what i should have said was that um
uh
uh this this space code that they that
they consider
is constructed from a special type of
graph so expander graphs which which
have been featured in in earlier talks
um and um and and
a result that they use is that um
we can perform uh random random cyclic
lifts
this is a result by agarwal and others
and um by doing so we still can preserve
the expansion properties of this graph
so now they do something more extreme
than in the
hastings hall or donald case they
take again the classical chord of length
and prime
as the base code however they choose the
fiber to be exponentially large
in in the size of the of the base code
[Music]
so now they obtain a quantum code again
the
the sizes just multiply
and the the problem here is that
again the degrees of freedom that we
encode are just determined by the
number of degrees of freedom we can
encode in the in the base code which is
only logarithmic
however they have a very elegant
averaging trick
and with this trick they can show that
the
the distance scales linearly
with with l so this is how they get
the almost linear distance
[Music]
so this is like the most extreme example
however they also show that there is
another
technique which is similar to the to the
distance balancing which they call
dimension balancing
and the idea is they take further
normal tensor products
[Music]
of of the codes of the quantum codes
with uh
uh with classical codes with parameters
we can control
very easily and
by forming this product we get a new
code
and since we can control the parameters
of the classic code very easily
we can we can kind of make a trade-off
between
the the distance of the code and the
number of encoder qubits
so there to use this parameter alpha
which is between zero and one
and we can essentially uh interpolate uh
along along this line of uh how we want
to have
uh like how we want to choose our number
of encoded qubits versus
their protection aka the distance
okay so this brings us to the to the
third example which are balanced product
quantum codes
these uh also are based on
two classical codes as uh as inputs
um however they also come with
an uh we assume that they come with an
associated symmetry group
and um the abstract idea here is
we can take just simply the normal
tensor product
of the of the classical codes and then
perform a symmetry reduction
and in fact this this idea is already
present uh
in this more algebraic language in the
uh in the lifted products
and yeah the outcome outcome is a
quantum code
but with reduced number of of physical
qubits so the symmetry reduction reduces
the number of physical qubits
however it leaves the other properties
more or less invariant okay so this
brings us to the question of how we can
obtain uh symmetrical codes
and um uh i i i'm sure um
uh many of you already know this but for
for those who don't um
the ingredients are expander graphs
which are
a certain type of graphs which have a
very strong connectivity property
and this connectivity property is
measured by the tiger constant
which is simply given by the
following ratio so we take some subset
of vertices
and we look at del s so this is just
number of edges which connects vertices
inside the set s with vertices outside
the set s
and we look at the ratio of the size of
this set with the size of
s and um if
this is very large then we have a good
expander
so for example if we look at a
a complete graph then this is a very
good expander however
this graph is an example of a very bad
expander since we can just take all
vertices on the let's say left-hand side
there's only a single edge connecting to
the right-hand side
um and for reasons that will become
clear in a moment
uh we were interested in photographs of
constant degree
um and uh so i should say that uh
hessing saudi and and uh
in the fire bundle and the lyft product
codes paper
both use expander graphs
and they essentially use a random graphs
which turn out to be
very good expanders however our
motivation or partial motivation was
that we wanted to have an
explicit meaning non-random construction
and it turns out that if we just take
graphs which kind of nicely embed in
hyperbolic space
then these tend to be very good
expanders
and in fact there's a
celebrated result due to lubotsky
phillips and zanak
who show that optimal expanders
can be achieved in this way and these
are calligraphs
of the two groups either pgl
or psl and in fact these can be kind of
thought of as
hyperbolic test relations which i will
kind of do
in this talk
okay so the other
ingredient are kind of turning turning
expander graphs into
into uh into codes um comes from zipster
and spiderman
and they show that we can combine
families of expander graphs
with local block codes just meaning
small local codes of constant size and
we can
use these ingredients to obtain families
of good classical codes
so let me give you uh a little fun
example so even for those of you who are
familiar with this uh i hope this is
kind of fun
um the idea or the example that i'm
showing you
is essentially a a graph which is
embedded
on a surface of gns3
so you can see it rotating in the upper
right hand corner
and the surface is tessellated by
triangles giving rise to this degree 7
graph and i want to define
a classical code on this
but i will do it different from what
people
in the classic in the quantum community
might think so i don't want to kind of
define my parity checks in terms of
putting putting qubits on the edges and
then
measuring the parity of all uh
cubits below belonging to sorry of all
edges belonging to a single vertex um
but what i want to do is i want to
measure or kind of constrain the the
edges
around the vertex to become code words
of a local code
and in my example i will i will consider
the 743
hamming code so you can see on the lower
right hand side
all code words up to cyclic uh
permutations of the hamming code because
it's a cyclic code
okay so let's say let's say i want to do
this
then um and let's say we want to kind of
see what uh
what what the code word of this code
looks like
um then uh let's start at some some
vertex let's start with the one in the
middle
and let's ensure that there is a code
word around this vertex
so if the the edge is grayed out it has
a zero
and if it has a thick line it has a one
so i will just take this highlighted
code word in the lower right hand corner
around this vertex and now you see that
since the the hamming code is a distance
three code
the vertices at the at the other
endpoints
cannot be cannot be very satisfied so
there are certainly checks
which pick up on uh on this
uh so i can try to fix this so i can
kind of try to build up
the code word but by doing this
iteratively so you can kind of think of
this as a
some sort of sudoku i will try to kind
of fix
[Music]
kind of try to kind of satisfy the
checks uh locally
by just building up larger larger code
words and you can see that
due to the due to the expansion of the
graph and the distance of the codes
they kind of uh forced me to kind of
build up larger and larger because i put
in more and more
thick edges into this picture
so again the expansion of the graph and
the distance of the local chord kind of
conspire
against me and force me to kind of build
chord words
of weight of order
of the size of the total graph so here
are just all the code words of this of
this code
so sorry this is just a basis set so
this code
encodes 12 bits
and by counting degrees of freedom i can
also show that
when i have do this i always get also
get a linear rate
so i hope this kind of example uh
convinces you
um of the general procedure that's laid
out by simpson spielman
is that by using expanders and local
codes
we can create test records explicitly
with good parameters
okay so this is the the ingredient that
we use for the balanced product
and again i want to kind of find a
retreat to the topological notion given
that
i i always have uh i can always kind of
uh
treat this uh this code so i can always
kind of embed this code on the surface
so i can kind of speak about about
topology
and um balance products already exist in
anthropology
so let's say i have two topological
spaces x and y and i have a group
acting on both spaces from the left and
from the right respectively
then we can define an anti-diagonal
action
on the cartesian product of these two
spaces
[Music]
and yeah by just taking the usual
cartesian product and then factoring out
this anti-diagonal action
we get a new we get a new topological
space
and this space is called the balance
product
okay
and yeah similarly to
hessings o'donnell and panteleife
kalachev we take products with
repetition codes
so we take an expander code which
exhibits some cyclic symmetry
a reputation code and the symmetry group
itself
and just to kind of again give you some
geometric intuition because i appreciate
this is a
slightly technical definition
[Music]
again our expander codes come with some
hyperbolic
rebound surfaces which is in which they
in which they embed nicely
and you can take this the surface and
you can just wrap it around itself
so a little bit like how you would store
socks in a
in a drawer you just kind of wrap them
around themselves and then we glue in
uh these circles in terms of repetition
code which are which are the recognition
codes
so this is kind of like the the
geometric picture
and um yeah just for the just for the
experts so people
uh um who are more familiar um
with let's say with the
homological description what we actually
deal with
is is called the double complex
and in this double complex our checks
are defined through boundary operators
and just what i can find very quickly
say here is
in this in this double complex these
the top left and the top right are our
qubits
and top left and bottom right
are the checks and
these these differentials kind of give
us our checks
and here highlighted is just the
differential of
the of the expander code itself so uh
what this shows is that
the keywords essentially see the checks
of the expander code
or in in the more geometric intuitive
picture
is we just have like this this large
this large surface on which lifts the
expander code
and um yeah all the
all the qubits in the surface
essentially only only see
the the checks of this expander code and
from this uh
i mean i i kind of i know um
get ahead of myself on this you can kind
of i know into it i hope
that one of the distances would in fact
be linear
in the in the total size of the system
okay so
let me not dwell too much on uh uh on
the ingredients here but
just to kind of again give some
intuition of where the parameters come
from
so we define our expander codes
using the rubotsky philips and thunder
construction
so that means we look at heli graphs of
pgl
of a finite field so the the order of
the final field kind of
[Music]
determines the the size of the of the
graph
and it also determines the size of the
cyclic symmetry which is always present
so we can kind of prove
that there's always a cyclic uh symmetry
group of size q
and the total size of the graph scales
like q to the three
and we can always guarantee that these
local codes
which also have to kind of fulfill some
technic condition that i didn't mention
we can guarantee that these two exist
using
a slight generalization of a result
due to gilbert and washerworth
so just to kind of show you the
properties of the codes that we get
the number of qubit scales with the with
the size of the graph of course
uh the number of logical uh logical
scales as
n to the uh two thirds and then as i as
i
just kind of uh mentioned a minute ago
the
the
that distance is in fact linear in the
system size
again you should kind of i know think of
this as just a one large
classical code wrapped around itself and
this is why the z distance
is linear the existence on the other
hand comes from
this cyclic fiber that we that we kind
of glued in
and this uh unfortunately always has a
size one-third
if we use pgl so this kind of comes from
uh
from this fact that we have q to the 3
here and q here
and then we can again take this do this
distance balancing procedure by taking a
product with a suitable
classical code and we obtain k
as n to the fourth fifth and d scaling
is
n to the three fifth okay we can kind of
i know maybe try different
different groups here but to get
different parameters
but we haven't found any let me just
kind of
quickly skip through this example
because i'm kind of running out of time
uh so just because i want to show you
that actually
uh uh you can construct these codes and
they are not
they're not too crazy so essentially
kind of taking the same example as i
showed you before
we can obtain a an example
on which has 546 physical qubits
it has six logical qubits and using some
monocolour brute force
we can upper bound the distances the
axis is exactly what we would expect
because our fiber has distance 13 so
this is exactly what we get
and that distance is 18 and
the checks are also not too large so
they are of weight six
and uh four to eight um for the zed
checks
so that's just to show you that um we
can kind of i know quite easily kind of
get like small examples
and actually this kind of scales quite
favorably to compare to the surface code
okay so the last point i want to make is
the
[Music]
we have these three examples of products
[Music]
however the balance product is a bit
different in the sense
that it's
somewhat more more general in the sense
that the fiber
is not restricted to be anything like a
circle or a torus
as it is the case for for the other
construction
in the in the language of lifted
products you can say that the associated
group algebra
which i didn't i didn't say this very
very clearly but we have i know uh
describe uh
the little products in terms of the
balance product
and then there's a group algebra
associated um
to the to the balance product and this
group algebra doesn't have to be
commutative
um so this leads us to a conjecture
and this conjecture is that we can use
balanced products
to actually build a good
ldpc quantum codes uh and the idea here
is that we just take
two suitable testing codes with suitable
symmetry groups acting on it
and by performing the balance product on
on both of them so instead of taking
one good code and one repetition code we
just take two good codes
and by doing this we obtain a good ldpc
point code
in fact we can already prove that the
encoding rate is linear so what's left
here is of course the hard part which is
the distance
okay so i'm kind of running out of time
so there were a few things that i didn't
talk about
one of them is all this can be cast in
the in the language of homology which is
quite natural
uh it streamlines a lot of a lot of
concepts um
and it makes proof simpler uh and
um just a shameless plug if you want to
uh no more about the background
um and kind of i know understand a
little bit more of the technical results
without kind of diving into the
into the three papers uh you can check
out this
uh perspective article that i wrote with
the co-author
so thank you very much for your
attention and i'm happy to take any
questions
we have time for one or two questions so
there's one in the q a
let me see um
in the balanced product code the linear
distance is for a slightly different
notion of distance right
so ie the subsystem code
oh right yeah yeah so that's like a
technicality um
so i can kind of find no uh so it's not
it's not for a different
uh notion of distance so we were quite
quite careful about this um
uh jesus
uh right so in this in this picture you
can kind of see it
so there might be there's a technical
problem
where uh the uh
the expander code might have uh the
parity checks might have fleeing
dependencies which lead
to uh qubits which have uh also which
lead to logical operators which have
um low weight so this doesn't have to be
the case
but we have no we have no proof that
this uh or we have no construction that
kind of excludes
this case uh however we can kind of uh
remove uh the um
[Music]
we can we can safely remove these uh
logical degrees of freedom and just have
declares engage degrees of freedom um
but again i want to kind of stress that
this is not for a different notion of
distance it's still the
it's still the true distance um
uh you just have to be very careful that
you can't just kind of
multiply a logical operator with a gage
operator
which could potentially reduce the
distance of uh
of of the product and
yeah this is something you have to be
kind of i know careful about
any other questions
all right well let's thank nicholas
again and all of the speakers in the
section